c'est à bord d'un paquebot naviguant
vers les états unis que dali et des
chars ne se rencontrent tant 1950 ils ne
se quitteront plus jusqu'en 1989 jusqu'à
la mort en fait du maître du surréalisme
mon père a gardé sa place auprès d'ali
pendant ces quarante années parce qu'il
a su rester un témoin
et surtout il n'a pas perdu la tête en
étant aux côtés de dali donc là vous
avez une photo qui illustre à 7 cette
relation cette complicité puisque daly a
même dédicacer un livre à mon père lui
disant des chambres le complice de mon
narcissisme peut-être le photographe
robert descharnes n'at-il pas sombrer
dans la folie en compagnie de dali parce
qu'il n'entrait pas dans son jeu mais se
voulait plutôt le témoin de ces
expérimentations ici en 1959 un rocher
et un bébé dauphin font cogiter
l'artiste
le jeudi le rocher arrive le vendredi
matin c'est le dauphin ils sont deux
formes symétriques
je dirais l'ins et la minéralité
l'éternité l'ofc et le biologique
l'éphémère donc tout est dit dans ce
dans cette association des deux des deux
objets au t2 des deux solides
vous pourrez dire et donc sa salle à
travailler et il a fait la théorie du
dur et d'humour
salvador au travail ou dali dans ses
délires une centaine de clichés
somptueux et présentés dans cette
exposition ainsi que des estampes et des
sculptures
mais la photographie à l'évidence jouer
une place de premier choix dans l'oeuvre
de l'artiste catalan
[Musique]